would you rather have your internet  history made public or a sex tape that  goes viral well again the entrepreneur  in me goes if a sex tape because i got a  dick on me so if the sex yeah it's not  bad dude uh  i mean it depends i don't know what we  deal with here man whether we got here  what are we doing i don't know i don't  know i don't know it's like we compare  banking to this compensation well i  don't know it's big you've had like  trill owens through here and [ __ ] i  don't know like if i say something dude  that's not big area is eight cool i  don't know dude i don't know i i don't i  don't know  we're talking about rap videos and [ __ ]  yeah thanks man  yeah you should have only been i should  have only found you know how many [ __ ]  how much money you could make listen if  this special doesn't do well phyllis  and you guys are doing your show and  you're like see shava's and only fans  no i'm at rock bottom